today's challenge is to play on an
inclined table we've got three setups
for you guys let's try them out a bit
more there we go yeah there we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this is this is already quite steep
[Music]
[Music]
we have to go steeper I don't know
what's like that no know what's
happening okay we get we're gonna make
it work there must be a way but how can
we how can we like keep the game going
like this
it actually was
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I got okay now say that slow point did
this yeah it's just the way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello there oh no it's fun
check what oh oh this is dev game you're
warned let's do one more sit up and do
it sideways it just looks really broken
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was a roller the first so that was
quite fun about this two last ones
didn't really work out so good third one
Oh sacré was actually quite okay but
probably not as fun that's the first one
anyway remember to help our channel and
subscribe here and watch our previous
episodes there until next time